A class works great when you want to produce a fleet of similar objects as
with the target code in this run.js example.
But what if you wanted a second category of objects that was
vaguely similar to this Car category?
Maybe you decide that in addition to enemy vans,
your game also needs cop cars that can be called to the player's aid.
So you decide that cops would behave pretty similarly to vans, but
they'd have a few important differences.
You'd probably need to refactor this code so
that the cops can behave a little bit differently.
So imagine cal is going to be one of these cops.
The cal object ought to have all the same vehicular powers as the other two
cars did.
What function could you use to build this object?